hi my name is reto Meier and I'm the
tech lead for Google's Android developer
relations team this efficient data
transfers dev byte is going to look at
techniques that you can use to reduce
the battery drain of your app without
affecting the freshness of your data by
adapting the frequency of your updates
based on context in other devbytes I've
explored ways to analyze your apps
transfer profile and optimize it using
techniques like prefetching bundling and
sync adapters and Google Cloud messaging
the goal is to ensure that you never
initiate a transfer that isn't related
to required data sync but if you have
server data that changes rapidly such as
breaking news weather or sports scores
creating an update every time there's an
update on the server is still going to
tax your servers and drain your users
battery particularly when your app is in
the background now the aim of this
devbyte us to go beyond limiting
transfers to win their valid and start
considering device state user behavior
and impact on the user experience to
minimize the number of updates that we
actually perform in my dev byte on
Google Cloud messaging you learned that
you can set your server messages to be
delayed when the device is idle as a
result your messages will be queued and
that queue is collapsed so that when
your app only receives one message when
the device becomes active now that's a
useful start as it prevents multiple
updates from happening when the user
isn't actually using the device in other
devbytes we've on using the sync adapter
you saw how to group all of your apps
transfer methods within your sync
adapters on perform sync method a sync
adapter can be triggered a number of
ways including GCM tickles client-side
changes scheduled updates or user
actions like selecting a new song or
browsing an article that hasn't been
prefetched within our perform sync
handle we need to determine which of
these triggers are sufficient to
initiate a new transfer starting with
scheduled updates periodic updates are a
great way to ensure your app never seem
stale and and that users aren't left
waiting for significant amounts of data
to be synced every time you open their
app of course it's stale is relative not
only to the type of data that your app
displays but also how frequently a user
opens your app periodic updates work
well for apps like news readers where
the frequent
you've news articles makes sending a GCM
message to every app whenever new
articles are available massive overkill
and the freshness of news isn't critical
unless the user happens to be actively
browsing it in this case performing a
background refresh every hour might be a
reasonable approach for users who open
the app several times a day as it
ensures that they see fresh headlines
every time they open the app even if the
device hasn't been online for a while
but it's wasteful for a user who only
reads the news headlines once each
morning now you can mitigate this by
reducing the background update frequency
based on the recency of app usage in
this snippet we check to see if the app
has been open since the last time we
performed a refresh if not we double the
period between refreshes now each time
the app is open we reset that counter so
as a result your app has fresher data
for regular users while those who open
the app only once a day or once a week
I saved the resulting battery drain now
if you're reducing the frequency of
updates to reduce the battery hungry use
of the cell radio we might be able to
mitigate some of these choices based on
the current battery level charging state
and our connectivity type it's generally
good practice to minimize background
updates when they don't result in
notifications but the impact of
performing updates while the device is
charging over AC is negligible so you
can reconsider some of those assumptions
when the device is connected to a
charger conversely you can listen for a
broadcast telling you that the device is
low on juice then reduce or eliminate
background updates completely until the
device is charging of course just
because you're connected to power
doesn't make your downloads free even if
you're not concerned with the power
drain associated with 3G radio you
should still be conscious of the amount
of data that you're transferring you can
also monitor the current internet
connection to help mitigate against that
if we're connected over Wi-Fi bandwidth
use isn't an issue and power uses
significantly lower than when compared
to a cell radio that means you can more
aggressively react to center sync
messages when client-side or client-side
content provider changes when you're in
the foreground and potentially even in
the background especially when we're
also connected to power a good example
of this scenario is when the device is
docked
muttering monitoring for the device to
be in adopt state can be a useful
shortcut
you know how to check for connectivity
and charging status and potentially
modifying a frequency at which you
perform syncs you can check the current
device state each time you receive a GCM
tickle or a local content provider
changes to determine if you should
actually perform the update or you can
monitor changes in the device state to
alter your sync adapter settings to stop
or start listening to changes likewise
you can send a message to your server
altering the frequency at which you want
to receive those sender sync messages
for example you may want to receive a
tickle after there are ten new headlines
or only when there is a breaking news
story in your area or not more
frequently than once every 10 minutes
you might also want to consider the
context of the user themselves using the
new activity recognition API as you can
choose to alter the foreground update
frequency based on what the user is
doing in this example we might
artificially limit the update rate when
they're doing anything other than
standing still on the basis that users
are less likely to be looking at the
screen and browsing now we can use a
similar technique as an alternative to
periodic updates rather than update the
app once every 24 hours to ensure it's
fresh in the morning
you might check for the tilting activity
after a prolonged period of being
stationary as an indication that the
user has been asleep and has now gotten
up in the morning so it's worth
refreshing their data now having
introduced a number of possible ways to
skip or delay transfers it's important
to check the cause of the sync to ensure
that you're not delaying transfers that
will affect the user experience directly
any manually initiate a transfer so
anything that's necessary for the user
to continue using the app or browsing
needs to happen straightaway when using
sync adapters you can determine this as
shown here now in any case while it can
be useful to alter the frequency at
which we execute a sync fundamentally
we're still depending on techniques like
sync adapters and Google Cloud messaging
as described in other devbytes in this
series to ensure that we only ever
consider performing a sync when data has
changed either on a client or on the
server even then we want to avoid
performing a sync that could be delayed
without impacting the user in most cases
that means being very conservative with
background updates for anything that
doesn't result in a notification being
displayed